joining us now for labor is the shadow
Chancellor Blake shelves hello to you
Mrs thanks for joining us you've got
your hands full now that they've got
their app together with Jeremy Hunt
the problem is Kay is that so much
damage has already been done this was a
crisis made in Downing Street but it is
ordinary working people who are paying
the price with higher mortgage costs and
higher borrowing costs and that's still
the same today as it was yesterday
before these chaotic zigzagging u-turns
but he knows that doesn't he um and he's
scrapped all of the um
almost all of the mini budget and it
does look as though he's going to
potentially increase taxes come the 31st
of October which is exactly what labor
would do isn't it
the problem is though is that anybody
who's coming off for fixed rate mortgage
deal and there's 1.8 million people in
that situation just by the end of next
year is looking at paying now 500 pounds
a month more on average because of the
um the the the problems that the Tories
have created and any combination of Tory
Prime Ministers and chancellors and
we've now seen four conservative
chancellors in just four months isn't
going to be able to undo that damage
that has been done both with our
International standing and with our
credibility in financial markets and
we're seeing that today when mortgage
rates continue to go up for ordinary
working people
what would you do you put taxes up
well I've said and you know okay I've
said this to you on many occasions that
the government should expand the
windfall tax on the big profits that
North Sea oil and gas companies are
making the government yesterday reduced
the amount of support that was available
for uh families and businesses with
their energy bills but he refused to
commit to an expansion of the windfall
tax that would help people with their
gas and electricity uh bills I've also
said that if you make Britain your home
you should pay your taxes here and
that's why as a labor government we
would abolish the non-dom tax status
that would bring in 3 billion pounds a
year the chancellor yesterday case spoke
about eye-wateringly difficult decisions
I don't think it is difficult to ask
people who make Britain their home to
pay their taxes here I don't think that
is difficult I don't think it is
difficult to ask oil and gas giants who
are making billions and billions of
pounds of profit to pay a bit more in
tax those are just some of the
differences between what an incoming
labor government would do compared with
what this conservative government is
doing
what about income tax how difficult
would it be to put that up
well I don't want income tax to to go up
I want taxes on working people to be low
which is why
um again for all of this year I've been
saying that increasing National
Insurance was the wrong priority in the
middle of a cost of living crisis to
increase taxes on working people and the
businesses who employ them was a mistake
I want to see a fair tax system at the
moment though those with the broadest
shoulders under the conservatives bear
the lightest load and that isn't by
accident that is by the choices of this
conservative government not just in the
last of 40 days under Liz truss's
leadership but the last 12 years of
conservative government
you've also said this morning that your
pose cuts to the police the NHS and
schools um how are you going to balance
the books
well you know that we so far have no
independent forecast from the office for
Budget responsibility so none of us know
the extent of the damage that the
conservatives have done to our public
finances but the truth is a month ago
nobody was talking about cuts to public
spending the only reason that these cuts
are now on the agenda is because of the
mess that the conservatives have made
now you know an arsonist is still an
arsonist even when they turn up at the
burning building with a bucket of water
this conservative government has put the
economy Up in Flames and they are not
the people to put out the fire that is
why it's time for not just another
conservative prime minister or another
conservative Chancellor it's time for
real change and a labor government that
would always put a financial stability a
fiscal responsibility first with a real
plan to grow the economy recognizing
that growth and prosperity comes from
the efforts of millions of working
people and thousands of ordinary
business is
the country obviously is in economic
crisis but how much do you think the
public appreciates the sort of
name-calling that we've seen from people
like your leader Sakia stamba allegedly
saying about Jeremy Hunt if you ever
need a sign of a Dying government it's
surely the return of Jeremy Hunt the man
who butchered the NHS risen from his
political grave I mean it's not really
appropriate to use that sort of language
it's surely that's below his eye level
well the latest Chancellor was one of
the key architects of austerity season
one and now he comes to the House of
Commons and says that what is needed to
fix the mess that he inherited from his
own government is austerity season two
well the truth is austerity season one
killed off the economic recovery and now
public services are on their knees and
the idea that what we need is another
round of cuts to essential Public
Services like our Health Service like
our schools and our police forces I just
do not accept that and the only reason
where we are in this position today is
because the damage that the
conservatives have caused we don't need
any more damage we need the government
now that puts economic stability respect
for Economic Institutions and growing
our economy through the efforts of
millions of working people first the
conservatives cannot fix the damage that
they've done it's time for Real Change
yeah but you know you talked about
windfall taxes I mean Jeremy Hunt
um has not ruled out to win full tax he
says I am not against the principle of
taxing profits that are genuine
windfalls nothing's off the table we'll
get on with it I've been saying for
months and months that the government
should expand the windfall tax but what
the government keep doing is borrowing
more money adding to the national debt
and failing to support families and
pensioners in the way that is absolutely
needed during a cost of living crisis so
you know to be honest I think many of us
are sick and tired of uh words what we
need is action to help people with the
cost of living crisis to restore
economic and financial uh stability and
also a real plan to grow the economy you
know I've set out Labor's green
Prosperity plan to invest in Tidal in
new nuclear in floating offshore winds
and carbon capture and storage and
modern industrial strategy to work in
partnership with businesses reforming
the outdated business rate system to
help our small businesses and high
streets to thrive a real plan for growth
and prosperity in all parts of the
country not just a failed trickle-down
economics of the conservatives
talk to me about coordinated strike
action a general strike this winter is
that something that labor supports I
don't want to see a general strike but I
do understand why working people when
they are faced with the inflation that
we see today or when they are faced with
the the increases in mortgage rates that
families and working people whether they
work in the public or the private sector
are facing I can understand why people
are standing up for their rights and
demanding higher pay we didn't see this
sort of industrial action under the last
Labor government because the last Labor
government respected ordinary working
people and worked with those Industries
and also with those trade unions to
resolve industrial disputes rather than
Fanning the Flames of them so instead of
Fanning the Flames I would urge the
government ministers to get around the
table with those Industries and with
those trade unions to resolve these
problems because at the moment we've got
working people who are struggling with
the rising cost of living and we've also
got working people who rely on those
essential Services who are struggling to
get to work and so you know we've got to
resolve this rather then the government
just seeing this as another
issue to divide people rather than
trying to bring the country together
what do you make of um secure backing
Tom Watson for a peerage
I've got a lot of time for uh Tom Watson
he was Deputy leader of the labor party
I think he's got an important
contribution uh to make I also welcome
the appointment of my old colleague Ruth
smeeve to the house of um Lords she was
a fantastic Member of Parliament but she
also faced a lot of abuse as a member of
Parliament and as a labor member at
Parliament for being a Jewish woman and
Kia's efforts to Stamp Out anti-Semitism
in the labor party I think is one of the
things that he deserves most credit and
respect for because anti-Semitism and
racism was a stain on the labor party
Kia's first priority when he became
leader of the labor party was to root
that out he has done that and I think it
is wonderful that Ruth Smith will now be
back in Parliament as a baroness in the
House of Lords
interesting that you use the word stain
it's the same word that Lord Lamont has
used saying it's a stain on the House of
Lords to give Tom Watson a life period
is it acceptable that someone who
supported false claims about a pedophile
ring within Westminster is being
rewarded in this way well Norman Lamont
of course was the last Chancellor to
crush the economy with uh black
Wednesday uh well I think it is an
important point because you know he was
the last chancellor who destroyed
Britain's economic credibility and saw
mortgage rates go through uh the roof
look yeah Beach ruin people's lives and
Tom Watson supported him
well look you know Tom Watson has made a
number of contributions he was wrong on
that uh that issue uh but he has made
many contributions as a parliamentarian
as Deputy leader of the labor party and
uh he's been rewarded with a position
now in the House of Lords but you know
I'm not going to take any lessons from
uh Lord Lamont the man who previously
crushed our economy
I can't believe that the one day that
you come into Westminster and I'm here
in Downing Street who knows you might be
behind the door of number 11 before too
long let's wait and see it's good to see
you as always thank you